bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7 8
l'actu sur TV Phil dernière semaine
avant de se retrouver en septembre pour
l'instant nous sommes en direct et voici
les titres si vous nous suivez donc à
18h à la route des vacances ou autre
surveillance policière plus sûr qu'en
2013 elles font néanmoins l'objet d'une
attention particulière en ce moment nous
faisons le point sur le dispositif en
place
une piste de ski à 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est en tout cas la volonté de
l'agglomération qui souhaite valoriser
le site de la colline d'Élancourt les
opposants ne manquent pas et notamment
les écologistes je recevrai ce soir
Olivier parejak au secrétaire d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts la pluie n'a pas
freiné le Nord irlandais McDowell ce
weekend il conserve son titre sur le
green de l'Alstom Open de France les
images les réactions et l'ambiance
autour du parcours de golf en fin de
journée dans une semaine c'est le 14
juillet Paris s'apprête à recevoir les
militaires pour le traditionnel défilé
sur les Champs-Élysées pour l'occasion
un grand concert sera aussi organisé au
Champ de Mars et c'est une entreprise
yvelinoise qui a été engagée afin
d'organiser ce chantier daynight Evans
qui a pour l'habitude d'organiser des
défilés de haute couture ou le festival
du mot des musiques du monde à Rabat et
pour la première fois ils vont
administrer l'un des plus gros
événements de l'année une semaine
intense de préparation une semaine où il
ne faut pas compter ses heures nous
avons suivi sur place Philippe yorio il
est régisseur général du Champ de Mars
et on l'écoute
donc tout ça c'est la partie scène
tout ce petit tout petites barres
d'aluminium c'est toute la partie saine
avec là donc là je voulais on protège on
protège le sol et pour stabiliser le sol
donc c'est des plats qu'on va qu'on
installe qui va permettre d'accueillir
toute la structure en fait de scène pour
la poser pour que ça stabilisé par
rapport au sol c'est 3 mois 3 mois en
préparation de dossier
c'est juste
je sais pas par jour on est à
toi des fois 6 heures du matin hier
c'était 6h du matin avant-hier 6h
pareil et puis jusqu'à temps que qu'on
soit dans le planning donc on n'est pas
dans le planning on n'arrête pas quoi
samedi matin premier jour de départ en
vacances petit retour en arrière sur
l'autoroute A10 au niveau du péage de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines c'est
l'encombrement dans le sens pareil
province jusqu'à 6000 véhicules
empreintes par heure cette plus grande
barrière péage d'Europe l'occasion de
faire le point sur les dispositifs
sécurité routières qui ont été mis en
place avec Catherine zulator
ce samedi matin le mot d'ordre pour les
gendarmes se montrer ils sont une
trentaine aux abords du péage de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines la plus grande
barrière de péage d'Europe c'est le
premier jour du départ en vacances entre
4500 et 6000 véhicules vont transiter
par heure vigilance accrue le préfet des
Yvelines est venu sur place pour
soutenir les équipes d'intervention
l'enjeu est d'importance les routes du
département ont enregistrées entre
janvier et mai 2014
488 accidents corporels 7% de plus en
comparaison à la même période de 2013
dans les Yvelines dans la situation un
peu paradoxale c'est que par rapport à
l'année on a plus d'accidents de la
route plus de blessés mais nettement de
moi de tuer donc c'est positif de ce
côté là néanmoins plus d'accidents c'est
préoccupant le mot d'ordre est lancé
pour cela il faut des moyens à commencer
par un hélicoptère qui sillonne une
large zone
réprimer et détecter les comportements
dangereux les dépassements par la droite
les gens qui zigzagent dans ces dans le
flot de circulation ce parfois qui même
empruntent la bande d'arrêt d'urgence
départ en vacances peut-être également
symbole de chargement parfois trop lourd
les véhicules sont posés la remorque de
ce landais présente une surcharge de 350
kg il devra s'acquitter sur le champ de
90 euros d'amende et répartir sa
surcharge dans la voiture d'un ami il
faut le faire c'est cette détection tout
de suite c'est pas quand il y aura
l'accident dans 200 ou 300 km donc nous
serons systématiquement
présent là aussi pour pour détecter et
le gros point noir pour les gendarmes ce
sont les excès de vitesse l'équipe
d'intervention de Saint-Arnoult on
Yvelines est équipé d'un véhicule rapide
capable d'atteindre les 250 km/h avec
leur radar ils peuvent capter une
vitesse à 800 mètres de leur position
dans leur cible les voitures qui roulent
à plus 260 km/h autre outil à
disposition une voiture banalis ée comme
on en croit à ce des dizaines sur la
route capable de se fondre sans souci
dans la circulation sauf que derrière
ces plaques d'immatriculation se cachent
un radar mobile nous venons d'être dotés
en fait d'un d'un radar automatique
embarqué dans un véhicule que nous
utilisons c'est vraiment pour moi ce
véhicule et ce moyen utilisé en
répression mais aussi en prévention
parce que on saura qu'on est là sur le
réseau secondaire essentiellement
entre janvier et mai 2014 197
infractions ont été relevées elle
concernait en majorité des grands excès
de vitesse et des défauts de permis de
conduire les gendarmes resteront très
mobilisées pendant cette période
estivale et notamment à la fin du mois
de juillet au moment du Grand chassé
croisé des vacances
et donc parmi les dispositifs vous
l'avez vu en place pour surveiller les
routes et puis pour relever les
infractions il y a cette voiture
d'intervention rapide dans une voiture
capable d'atteindre les 250 km heure
pour intercepter ces automobilistes qui
sont en grand excès de vitesse des
images dès le 10 moines et de Claire
Cambier
ce véhicule est exclusivement destiné à
travailler sur autoroute et voie express
donc la particularité il est équipé d'un
panneau un message variable qui nous
permet de communiquer avec les usagers
de la route
il est équipé aussi donc de feu
icla derrière de génération d'une
nouvelle génération de gyrophare donc à
l'aide tournant et également à l'avant
du véhicule donc on a également équipé
de foi éclats à la base du pare-brise ce
qui nous permet en fait d'être visible
lors d'un bon d'interception notamment
ce samedi matin il pleut sur l'autoroute
A10 le flux de voiture ne fait
qu'augmenter en ce jour de premier
départ en vacances
donc là on va aller se positionner dans
un endroit sécurisé pour nous et on va
procéder un contrôle vitesse donc là on
travaille en sens 2 c'est à dire les
gens qui vont se diriger vers Paris
un véhicule sportif capable d'atteindre
les deux 150 km/h le but intervenir le
plus vite pour faire stopper
l'infraction rapidement on travaille
exclusivement à la vitesse voilà mais on
peut aussi travailler dans le cadre
d'une façon plus générale dans le
contrôle des flux c'est-à-dire que même
dans le flux de circulation on peut
également relever les infractions
simplement des gens qui vont dépasser
par la droite les gens qui vont circuler
sur la voie de gauche en permanence avec
ce radar appelé cinémomètre les
gendarmes peuvent contrôler les voitures
à plus de 800 mètres de leur position ce
qui les intéresse les vitesses
supérieures à 160 km heure
BMW Série 3 Coupé
les patrouilleurs prennent la route dans
leur ligne de mire une voiture allemande
contrôlée à 161 km/h en quelques
secondes il se positionne au côté du
véhicule donc là je vais actionner le
panneau à un message variable et je vais
demander à la conductrice de le suivre
dans un endroit sécurisé les
patrouilleurs font stopper la voiture la
conductrice est un médecin urgentiste
qui vient de finir 36 heures de garde
161 km/h c'est une vitesse enregistrée à
laquelle nous appliquons une tolérance
puisque c'est prévu comme ça par la loi
ce qui fait une vitesse retenue de 150
km/h d'accord donc là vous restez dans
le cadre d'une amende de 4e catégorie
c'est-à-dire 90 euros si la montre
forfaitaire minorée et vous pouvez
perdre deux points sur votre permis de
conduire dans le véhicule le second
gendarme entre les données sur un
terminal informatique mon collègue est
en train de vérifier à l'aide du
terminal informatique embarqué la
validité du permis de conduire voilà la
situation du véhicule et également s'il
s'agit ou non d'une personne recherchée
voilà en fait on interroge plusieurs
fichiers ça se fait comme ça à savoir
donc s'il s'agit d'un véhicule volé ou
pas
le fichier des permis de conduire dans
une semaine cette conductrice va
recevoir son infraction par courrier les
gendarmes reprennent leur route dans
l'unité de Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines ils
sont trois être formés cette conduite
rapide en une matinée ils auront
verbalisé trois grands excès de vitesse
vendredi soir à 21h une bagarre avec la
terre à la Fête des Loges à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye après le refus
d'un jeune homme d'une vingtaine
d'années de payer pour un tour d'auto
tamponneuse accompagné de plusieurs
personnes le ton est monté entre son
groupe et celui de forain venu en
renfort une enquête est aujourd'hui en
cours puisque le jeune est plongé
maintenant dans un coma artificiel avec
un grave traumatisme crânien la vitesse
ce soir Olivier pareja bonsoir vous êtes
le co-responsable dans le département
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts on va
aborder avec vous l'idée de création
d'une piste de ski à 50 ans sur la
colline d'elle en cours anciennement
colline de la revanche vous êtes opposé
à ce projet je précise que nous avions
convié pour débattre le responsable du
dossier pour la ville d'Élancourt il ne
souhaite pas pour l'instant venir sur le
plateau le projet n'est pas encore assez
avancé c'est ce qui nous a expliqué il
accepte de venir en revanche après les
vacances une fois que d'autres réunions
publiques auront été organisées nous
relancerons donc l'invitation en
septembre ou en octobre et vous serez
une fois de plus le bienvenu vous
pourrez échanger merci pour l'instant on
va tout de même l'écouter ce responsable
du dossier puisque nous l'avons
rencontré lors de la toute première
réunion publique en fin de semaine
dernière et voici ce qu'il répond à vos
inquiétudes
je dirais qu'il est prématuré déjà de se
prononcer sur un projet qui a pas été
présenté vous voyez notre propre équipe
municipale a pas toutes les
connaissances techniques du projet
certes il y a eu des brides qui sont
partis ici ou là mais quand on en est à
l'état d'avancement de tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire d'avant-projet
d'ores et déjà dire qu'on est contre ça
me paraît un petit peu
présomptueux de leur part de pouvoir
s'avancer avec autant d'affirmations que
ce soit sur les aspects de consommation
ou environnementales ils n'ont
absolument pas entendu comment souhaiter
mettre en oeuvre le projet et sont déjà
compte je trouve ça un petit peu bizarre
Olivier pareja vous avez entendu le
maire adjoint de la ville d'Élancourt
qui s'occupe de l'Urbanisme et de ce
chantier plus particulièrement de piste
de ski de ski-dom parce que c'est le nom
qui a été retenu vous dites quoi c'est
trop tôt pour s'inquiéter non c'est pas
nécessairement trop tôt pour s'inquiéter
on peut tout à fait exprimer nous aussi
notre opinion le projet n'est quand même
pas nouveau c'est un projet qui est
récurrent qui depuis des dizaines
d'années revient de temps en temps le
code esqui l'a étudié l'année dernière
par exemple il y a un dossier très
intéressant qui est en ligne sur le site
de la communauté d'agglo et communauté
enfin conseil communautaire un conseil
qui réunit plusieurs personnes de la
population civile qui s'exprime sur des
dossiers concernant
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le codeski
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas voilà
qui donne un avis consultatif qui peut
après orienter les décisions de la
communauté d'agglo donc en fait dans ce
dossier du codeski on voit qu'il y a
déjà des choses qui sont posées sur ce
projet là donc il est pas trop tard pour
il est pas trop tôt pardon pour
commencer à exprimer des doutes sur la
pertinence de construire ce qu'on peut
imaginer comme étant un gros frigo de
plusieurs centaines de mètres sur la
colline vous allez nous expliquer
justement plus en détail les raisons de
votre position pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas ce dossier même si
vous l'avez dit on en parle depuis
maintenant 10 20 30 ans même de cette
piste de ski sur la colline d'Élancourt
voici un reportage qui repose les choses
c'était lors de la première réunion
publique en fin de semaine dernière donc
320 mètres de descente pour skieur et
snowboarder abrité sous un complexe de
22000 m² sur le sommet de la colline
d'Élancourt et maintenu à une
température de moins 5 degrés toute
l'année une image qui fait froid dans le
dos pour les écologistes et une partie
des riverains venus en nombre pour cette
première réunion publique de
concertation organisée en mairie le 3
juillet
alors rien à faire ici cette piste de
ski ici il y a pas de neige il y a rien
il est préférable de végétaliser et puis
de faire des promenades enfants enfin
famille c'est certainement plus
intéressant que de faire un skido qui va
dénaturiser le site et il a vu donc
c'est ridicule c'est un projet privé qui
va ramener des capitaux pour du privé
avec des subventions publiques et si le
projet ne fonctionne pas ça redeviendra
une charge pour le public c'est à dire
pour les impôts des citoyens
représentant de la ville et de la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines souhaitait
simplement présenter à la population la
procédure de révision du PLU le plan
local de l'urbanisme qui doit permettre
de rendre le site constructible ils ont
également été obligés de s'expliquer sur
leurs intentions pour l'instant le
projet n'est pas validé il devrait être
examiné par les élus de la majorité
j'aime mélancourt mais aussi par les
deux groupes les trois groupes
d'opposition de la commune ils seront
consultés nous les écouterons et après
si le projet est validé par l'ensemble
des élus à la fois d'Élancourt et de la
communauté d'agglomération bien
évidemment il y aura une réunion de
concertation où là on rentrera dans les
aspects techniques du projet les
principaux acteurs locaux du dossier
s'il soutiennent l'idée assure que cela
ne se fera pas sans de nombreuses
garanties en termes d'environnement mais
aussi financière la société SnowWorld
qui développera le skidome comme elle
l'a déjà fait au Pays-Bas attend quant à
elle un investissement de taille avant
de s'installer infrastructure de
transport et de déplacement notamment
500 places de parking sur NSR avant que
le projet ne devienne réalité après
avoir été lancé pour la première fois
voici 20 ans d'autres réunions publiques
sont déjà annoncées pour la rentrée si
les plus optimistes parlent d'une
ouverture en 2017 les canons à neige
artificiels ne sont pas encore prêts à
être déployés
je reçois donc Olivier paraja pour
Europe Écologie Les Verts le premier de
vos arguments au-delà de l'environnement
c'est que ça va coûter cher parce qu'on
l'a entendu il faut des places de
parking il faut des infrastructures pour
le déplacement ça coûte très cher
effectivement si c'est un projet privé
sur sur un site qui appartient à la
communauté d'agglomération on peut
imaginer que nécessairement tous les
aménagements collectifs que ça soit des
routes que ça soit des places de parking
etc reviendront à être payé par la
collectivité donc ça va être encore une
subvention un projet qui est
complètement privé et surtout un projet
qui pour nous n'a pas de sens au niveau
écologiste au niveau de la transition
énergétique sur laquelle il faut
maintenant se pencher toujours sur
l'aspect financier parce que ça va
coûter cher aussi de s'y rendre pour les
particuliers vous imaginez que ça ne se
s'adresse pas spécialement à la
population de 50 ans Nîmes les noms on
parle d'une cinquantaine d'euros pour
une vingtaine d'euros de l'heure c'est
ça les chiffres sont ceux qu'on peut
qu'on peut voir pour les installations
similaires de la même société en
Hollande donc on peut imaginer que ça
sera la même chose il serait la une
chose ici il y a Saint-Quentin donc à 50
euros la journée plus nécessairement les
consommations sur place c'est pas
quelque chose pour tout le monde et
quand on nous parle du fait que les
enfants de la communauté
d'agglomérations vont pouvoir aller au
ski c'est quand même pas du tout la même
chose d'enfermer les enfants pendant
quelques heures dans un hangar
frigorifique
éclairé artificiellement que de les
emmener ne serait-ce que dans une classe
de découverte ou d'autres activités qui
sont beaucoup plus formatrices beaucoup
plus intéressantes que que simplement le
fait de faire du ski dans un endroit
fermé on en vient à l'environnement même
si les principaux acteurs on entendait
avec ce reportage assure qu'on fera
attention à l'environnement parce qu'il
y a des obligations pour vous ça va tout
de même à l'encontre de ce plan énergie
climat pour réduire l'empreinte carbone
du territoire qui avait été voté mis en
place par la Communauté d'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin mais je pense que on a
de nos jours un certain nombre d'alerte
que ça soit des alertes par exemple des
experts du GIEC le dossier est sorti il
y a quelques mois donc qui nous alertent
sur le fait que
le réchauffement climatique est quelque
chose qui est dû à l'activité humaine un
des dossiers du Jay qui est aussi très
intéressant puisqu'il nous disent que ce
n'est pas inéluctable c'est à dire que
effectivement il y a des choses qui sont
dues à l'activité humaine mais que on
peut imaginer
atténuer les effets et donc qui dit
atténuer les effets dit ne pas se lancer
dans des projets qui vont à l'encontre
du fait de consommer de l'énergie là où
c'est pas nécessairement
utile donc c'est pas nécessairement qui
qu'il faut tout arrêter qu'il faut plus
rien faire simplement on n'est pas
nécessairement obligé de continuer à
faire des projets qui soient
consommateurs et d'énergie imaginez un
hangar de plus de 300 mètres de long sur
50 à 100 mètres de large le maintenir à
5 degrés pendant toute l'année y compris
en été c'est quand même quelque chose
qui va consommer des des milliers de
kilowattheure des millions de kilomètres
de kilowattheure ça se fait ailleurs la
Hollande Pays-Bas ça se fait vous avez
regardé ce qui se passait ailleurs
est-ce que ça fonctionne est-ce que ça
ne vous rassure pas sur la faisabilité
sur l'intérêt d'avoir nouvel équipement
mais en termes économique aussi parce
que ça va ramener aussi de l'emploi et
on peut tout à fait on l'a entendu dans
votre portage je les habitants ont des
idées ont des projets alternatifs donc
pourquoi ne pas les écouter je m'inscris
en faux par rapport à la personne de la
mairie d'Élancourt qui dit les élus vont
décider vous les élus vont être vont
vont réfléchir et ensuite on présentera
la population on peut imaginer quand
même une procédure un tout petit peu
plus participative où on demande aussi
aux élans courtois et plus généralement
aux 50 chinois leur avis qui puisse dire
si eux ils veulent un skidome s'ils
veulent plutôt des de la verdure s'ils
veulent plutôt des activités sportives
sans nécessairement que ça soit
réfrigéré ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'après la réunion publique qui a eu
lieu jeudi un collectif citoyen c'est
monté donc il y a déjà un site internet
depuis jeudi donc c'est c'est donc le
site c'est amis de la revanche point
zone libre.info voilà amis de la
revanche pointée
sur ce site ça va toutes les
contributions de toutes les personnes
qui ont une idée d'un projet vont
pouvoir être publiés de façon à élargir
le débat et pas attendre que les élus
étrangers pour le présenter à la
population quel serait le projet idéal
pour vous imaginez comment l'avenir de
cette colline parce qu'au bout d'un
moment il va falloir tout de même
l'aménager ça fait tout à fait longtemps
que cette colline là pour ceux qui
arriveraient à ces récemment qui sera
arrivé assez récemment sur 50 ans en
Yvelines on rappelle que c'est constitué
de des dégravas qui ont permis
l'émergence de cette ville nouvelle de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines artificielle
voilà et ce qui me fait ce qui me fait
dire aussi que dans les obstacles
techniques qui expliquent aussi que le
projet n'est pas encore pour l'instant
abouti c'est que il reste quand même le
problème de la pollution de de ce
terrain là qui doit être levé avant
qu'on le construise dessus de la même
façon que la mairie d'Élancourt dit
qu'il va falloir réviser le PLU mais
peut-être à minima c'est aussi des
choses qui restent des choses techniques
à étudier avant que un projet soit plus
avancé et votre projet pour en revenir à
cette question vous l'imaginez comment
l'avenir le projet peut tout à fait être
quelque chose qui qui tourne autour du
sport qui soit peut-être des sports de
glisse pourquoi pas mais quelque chose
qui s'inscrive dans la Base de Loisirs
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui
préserve les ressources naturelles comme
la réserve ornithologique qui est juste
à côté des projets beaucoup plus
peut-être moins comment moins bling
bling -
attirer toute la population de toute
l'Île-de-France sur ce site là au risque
de toutes les nuisances on imagine 300
000 personnes venir par an donc ça veut
dire
c'est près de d'un millier par jour donc
il y a énormément de nuisances on
pourrait imaginer un projet tout en
restant sportif qui soit beaucoup plus
tourné vers les 50 chinois lorsque vous
parlez de la fréquentation c'est 300 000
personnes ça veut dire qu'il y a une
vraie attente aussi
c'est les chiffres que donne l'opérateur
qui se fait et que ça marche ça veut
dire qu'il y a une attente c'est-à-dire
que tout le monde n'est pas non plus
convaincu que ce soit un mauvais projet
ah mais j'imagine bien qu'il y a des
gens qui trouvent que c'est un bon
projet sinon ils sont là il serait pas
là ils sont pas venus là pour le
défendre mais mais c'est attendu en tout
cas il y a une demande pour ça c'est ce
que nous dit l'opérateur mais on peut
tout à fait imaginer que le rôle des
élus ça soit aussi de trouver des
projets qui intéressent localement les
50 Chinois et les élans courtois qui
sont rendus massivement à la réunion qui
a eu lieu jeudi il y avait une
opposition avant la création du vélo de
Rome à Montigny-le-Bretonneux Europe
Écologie les versets étaient opposée
d'ailleurs cette création pour autant le
Vélodrome a vu le jour comment vous
allez vous organiser cette fois-ci pour
vous faire entendre et que ça porte ses
fruits alors l'Europe Écologie Les Verts
et pas tout seul c'est ce que je disais
il y a ce collectif citoyen qui s'est
monté je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
associations commençant pour Élancourt
qui existent depuis depuis un moment
donc nécessairement ce qui est important
c'est que les citoyens puissent
proposer des projets altern puisse
montrer qui sont contre après
nécessairement il y a des choses qui se
font quand même le vélodrome c'était pas
tout à fait le même contexte c'était
plus aussi un côté PPP qui était
partenariat public privé qui est qui
reste dangereux pour les finances de la
casquette là on n'est pas sur ce sur ce
projet là c'est c'est à nous à démontrer
aussi la pertinence d'un projet
alternatif et nous en parlerons bien sûr
à la rentrée encore de ce dossier de
piste de ski à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
en cours plus particulièrement merci
Olivier parigeat et d'être venu ce lundi
soir pour nous expliquer vos réticences
écologie on passe au sport pour terminer
ce journal après 4 jours de compétition
de haute volley au terme d'un final
temps c'est l'Irlandais McDowell qui a
conservé son titre l'appstom Open de
France côté français 4 jours plus tôt
tout le monde avait Dieu pourtant que
pour Victor Debuisson le français
Anthony Rech
de mémoire de golfeur lors d'un premier
tour on avait rarement vu autant de
monde autour du départ du trou numéro 1
de l'Albatros personne ne veut louper
l'entrée en lice du numéro 1 français a
commencé par le secrétaire d'État au
sport en visite au Golf National
contrairement à d'autres sports pour ce
tennis ou lorsqu'il y a un grand tournoi
on sait que c'est trois ou quatre
joueurs qui peuvent gagner là à chaque
fois si on met une vingtaine dans les
vins il y a toujours des Français c'est
vrai que cette année tout le monde met
la pression sur Victor Dubuisson et il a
quatre jours pour pour bien péter pas
faire d'erreur et on sera derrière lui
bien sûr
pour ce premier tour Victor Dubuisson va
affronter l'Albatros au côté de deux
grands favoris le tenant du titre grem
McDowell et le favori allemand Martin
keimerait 12 vainqueur de l'US Open mais
ce que personne n'osait croire arrive
dès le premier drive le 22e joueur
mondial sera complètement et envoie sa
balle hors du fairway après deux trous
ils se retrouvent même à 4 coups du parc
en favori quoi avec tout le public qui
le porte et je pense que c'est y a mis
un petit peu la pression et je vais des
très grands joueurs donc ça va le tirer
vers le haut et ça le stimuler je pense
qu'il y a un gros mental il va revenir
dans la partie malheureusement pour ces
supporters le numéro 1 français ne se
remet pas de ce triple Boguet il finira
cette première journée à plus 5 loin
derrière la démonstration de l'américain
Kevin Stadler qui pour sa première
apparition sur l'Albatros se retrouve
seul en tête avec une carte de 64
l'eau de consolation côté tricolore
c'est un autre Victor élu qui occupe la
place de premier procès il conclut ce
premier tour au sixième rang sur les
deuxièmes et 3e jour le titre semble
s'offrir à stade l'heure toujours
imperturbable avec dans son sillage
l'étonnant Victorius solide dauphin à
quatre coups mais ça c'était avant que
la puissance mène dimanche avis de
tempête sur le golfe nationale mais
aussi dans les mains de Kevin Stadler
américain de 34 ans craque complètement
et se fait croquer par grem McDowell
pourtant partie avec huit coups de
retard le Nord irlandais arrive au Club
House en leader mais doit attendre le
dernier trou de stade leur si
l'Américain rentre ce dernier pote il
peut s'offrir une mort subite
un raté qui offre la victoire à mcdoel
le Nord irlandais conserve son titre
également le plus grand retour d'un
vainqueur lors d'un dernier tour de
l'histoire du tournoi
aujourd'hui c'était une bonne journée je
ne m'attendais pas à gagner j'ai
beaucoup de chance d'être assis à côté
de ce trophée
la plus grosse différence pour moi
aujourd'hui c'était les fairway
avec la pluie c'est drôle comment l'eau
a rendu des reufs plus dense ils sont
devenus plus lourds et la balle plutôt
que de s'arrêter sur le roef avait
tendance à glisser
j'ai été chanceux mais j'ai dû aussi
jouer de nombreux coups sur le fairway
et ce lundi soir Anthony Reich vous
propose un 7 8 sport dédié en partie à
l'Open de golf rendez-vous 18h30 19h30
et 23h sur notre antenne il sera aussi
question de BMX avec les images du
championnat de France qui vient de se
tenir au vélo de route nationale à
Montigny le Bretonneux merci de nous
avoir suivis le journal revient demain
mardi au même heure bonne soirée